I am really stressed out about finding
this turkey because I've called 12
different butchers 12 different farms
and I'm like I don't know if this is
possible we're praying for his airway
smear do have to kill the turkey Zee
Rosi Rosi zero I'm gonna be trying to
cook a turkey zero waste I think that
it's gonna take away more time to find a
turkey zero waste and way more money
because we're probably gonna have to go
to a specialty place so I think that Ari
found someone all right what's going on
okay great okay okay thank you we got a
place yeah all right so here I have two
different size pots and also a big
reusable bag just in case I don't know
what how big this turkey is gonna be I
could get organic a whole army Wow
where do you get turkeys we get them
from on a farm in savior California and
they come alive and we slaughter them
here and we take the feathers out clean
it all that stuff with the turkey
we were not prepared for the size of the
turkey
do you think that'll be good I don't
know if it'll fit
Oh
Wow I love turkeys especially the turkey
leg the turkey leg is my favorite part
of the turkey did I mention I love
turkey legs Oh Carrie we did it so we
took the turkey out of the bags and I'm
washing the reusable bags with stalling
hot water and soap because you don't
want to mess around with turkey juice
I'm gonna make it great very sticky
yes so we're gonna make some butter guys
using whole cream in a reasonable bottle
so I'm just thanks I'm just gonna pour
it in here and now we just here's our
butter
so we all know the main dish is the
turkey today but what's turkey with
awesome sides so we are going to be
cutting up potatoes and cutting up some
onions I'm putting it in the bottom of
the pants we roasted perfectly and
making some Brussels sprouts and
broccolini we're also gonna cut up some
lemons and put it in the turkey Rose I
got all these things package free from a
local store in LA called cookbook so the
inside of the turkey came with some I
would say waste yeah we were expecting
it to be plastic but it turns out it was
actually paper cute so cute we love a
good liver so I'm a vegetarian but every
year I cook a turkey with my grandma Oh
Dan there's still a feather on that
thing I'm gonna pluck it oh that's some
freshly butchered turkey no we just put
it in there zero waste also means trying
to reduce food waste so we're taking all
our vegetable scraps and we're going to
be making a soup with it as well as with
the bits of the turkey first we're gonna
roast it for 30 minutes once you carve
the turkey we're gonna take the carcass
of the turkey I'm gonna make a soup Oh
Lord this is gigantic this thing is so
big Thanksgiving from my family is a
really big deal we love being around
each other cooking my dad is the best
chef that I ever met and his
Thanksgiving meals are always grand
it looks like the table from the beauty
and beasts movie it's also Tyler we do
musical performances and plays and
listen to a lot of Asian music cuz you
know I we didn't find this little
plastic piece in the turkey holding its
legs together but we took it out because
we don't want to cook it so now we're
gonna butter the turkey and add herbs
and salt
I'm putting the butter underneath the
skin you see how he gets in there I'm
getting a little too in there for my
liking what do you do when you make
stuff you don't touch it with your hands
I usually don't there's nothing I love
more than a turkey legs on
she's nice planet you know when again to
every single you're making me feel
uncomfortable what's happening
I'm stuffing some garlic underneath the
skin also we've been watching your hand
out this whole process we're gonna put
some salt on it - oh God
what you me about we're gonna put some
herbs - rosemary make it look like
Julius Caesar I love her now we're gonna
go put him in the oven turkey Turkey
turkey Turkey it's gonna go in the oven
at 325 for about four and a half hours
the rule is 15 minutes per pound of
turkey don't we love man we've been
basting every half hour like good
basters like good beasties it's really
gigantic and handing it out it's heavy I
am so excited it smells so good so
there's also this little plastic thing
that says when it's cooked but we have
our own meat thermometer but that's also
gonna be a part of our trash burn in the
oven
it's ready oh wow what a bird now we're
gonna test some meat temperature got to
put it in next to the bone to get the
best reading rule keeps going up it's at
171 showing me great because it needs to
be at 165 for it to be safe to eat no
one's gonna die no one we didn't even
have a fight look at it our Turkey our
18 pound turkey it's a little burnt on
the top but it's still gonna be tasty
honestly I'd rather have it well cook
than undercooked
okay I'm gonna carve into this puppy I'm
so excited that she's welding my knife
about me I'm not making any promises
like I know what I'm doing but it seems
hot turkey leg for me you know I look
turkey leg Betty why are you really
going after sorry just cutting into a
carcass and you're not gonna eat it okay
so we did it let's eat yes let's eat I'm
gonna watch you eat this turkey get that
gravy
[Music]
mmm is it okay as it dries and moist
tell me it's a warrant can you taste the
herbs the lemon very like the sits under
a roast over fire try the potato I
definitely get garlic notes
I don't soft but then it has a bit of a
crunch the greens are super tasty long
time I've never had what is it broccoli
honestly sure suppose your original
broccoli I love it maybe we are tasty
chefs so we lost some time because we
had to call a bunch of places but we
only have to go to one place this was
all the trash that was in the turkey
this is so impressive yeah how does it
stack up with other turkeys looking
online for an 18 pound organic turkey
the average price was around $120 and we
got this turkey for $54 we gotta go get
miss turkey to some people we're gonna
go there just a meat-eating people cuz
it's just probably Thanksgiving the
carcass the noise you're making and it's
gonna be a suit for Joyce because Joyce
doesn't have to buy groceries for the
next week
turkey days turkey day I'm gonna eat
some turkey let zero waste ur turkey day
zero waste two turkey day it's take it
take it take it take it take it take it
turkey bag